N
THE SPRING.
BUSES IN NEW JERSEY WARNING
ABOUT RADIATION POISONING.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO IN A
RADIATION EMERGENCY?
NO, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THIS IS ALL MAKE-BELIEVE,
PLAY-ACTING.
IF YOU LIVE IN A BIG METRO AREA,
THERE'S NOT ANYTHING YOU'RE
GOING TO DO DURING A NUCLEAR
EXCHANGE, BECAUSE YOU'LL BE DEED
ALONG WITH MOST OTHER AMERICANS.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS WILL BE DEAD.
THOSE WHO SURVIVE WILL STARVE TO
DEATH BECAUSE ALL AGRICULTURE
WILL BE DESTROYED, ALONG WITH
BILLIONS OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
PLANET.
SO IT'S TIME TO UPDATE YOUR
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY
HERE.
THESE ARE NOT THE BOMBS THAT
FLATTENED NAGASAKI.
THEY ARE INCALCULATEBLY MORE
POWERFUL.
YOU HIT NEW YORK.
YOU TAKE OUT MIAMI.
SO A NUCLEAR WAR MEANS NOT THAT
WE GET TO TAKE OUT THE BLACK SEA
FLEET.
IT MEANS THE END OF THE WORLD.
AND PEOPLE WHO WORK AROUND THIS
STUFF UNDERSTAND IT.
THEY'RE REALLY AFRAID.
NO ONE ELSE SEEMS TO HAVE ANY
IDEA.
WHY IS THAT?
GLEN GREENWALD HAS BEEN WATCHING
THIS UNFOLD.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
IT SEEMS TO ME, NO MATTER HOW
YOU FEEL ABOUT PUTIN, UKRAINE,
THE WAR, ANYTHING, THE THREAT,
THE VERY REAL IN-YOUR-FACE
THREAT OF A NUCLEAR EXCHANGE
RIGHT NOW THAT THEY'RE OPENLY
TALKING ABOUT WOULD REQUIRE THE
MEDIA TO START TELLING PEOPLE,
HEY, THIS IS REAL, BUT NOBODY
IS.
I WONDER WHY THAT IS.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
AMERICAN WARS, TUCKER, OVER THE
LAST COUPLE DECADES, THEY'RE
INCREDIBLY SIMILAR, THE WAY THEY
CONVINCE AMERICANS TO SUPPORT
U.S. INVOLVEMENT IN A WAR, THEY
PERSONALIZE A PARTICULAR LEADER,
GET US TO HATE THAT LEADER.
OH, SADDAM HUSSEIN IN IRAQ IS A
TERRIBLE GUY.
IN SYRIA, HE'S A TYRANNICAL
FORCE.
GADHAFI IN LIBYA.
YEAH, LET'S TAKE OUT THESE
TYRANTS.
THEN, YOU KNOW, HUNDREDS OF --
OF -- OF -- OF BILLIONS DOLLARS
LATER, AND LIVES LOST, POLLS
ALWAYS SHOW THAT AMERICANS COME
TO REALIZE THEY REGARD THOSE
WARS AS A MISTAKE.
AND THE REASON IS THEY REALIZE
THAT NO BENEFITS CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES AND AMERICAN
CITIZENS BY VIRTUE OF U.S.
INVOLVEMENT IN THOSE WARS.
LET'S APPLY THAT FRAMEWORK HERE.
THE CONSENSUS IN WASHINGTON IS
THAT WE ARE CLOSER TO THE USE OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAN AT ANYTIME
SINCE THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS
60 YEARS AGO.
THERE'S A VERY REAL THREAT OF A
NUCLEAR EXCHANGE, OR EVEN A
DIRECT CONFRONTATION WITH RUSSIA
AND THE UNITED STATES.
AND OVER WHAT?
OVER WHO GOVERNS AND RULES, NOT
EVEN UKRAINE, BUT THE DONBAS,
THE EASTERN REGION IN UKRAINE,
WHERE A MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
IDENTIFY AS ETHIC RUSSIANS AND
WANT TO BE RUSSIANS, AND THERE'S
NO HUGE DEBATE ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF A NUCLEAR WAR,
BECAUSE EVERYONE KNOWS THE
MINUTE YOU STEP UP AND STEP OUT
OF LINE, THERE'S A HOARD OF
PEOPLE READY TO CALL YOU
UNPATRIOTIC, A TRAITOR, AN
ADMIRER OF VLADIMIR PUTIN, AS I
KNOW IS BEING DONE WITH OUR VERY
SEGMENT RIGHT THIS MINUTE BY ALL
THOSE MEDIA MATTER PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE ONLINE.
IT'S A REPRESSIVE ATMOSPHERE.
IT'S SQUASHING A DEBATE THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO HAVE.
>> Tucker: WE'RE LOSING TRACK OF
REALITY.
IF A NATION HAS NUCLEAR WEAPONS,
AND YOU BELIEVE EVEN
THEORETICALLY THEY MIGHT USE
THEM, YOU HAVE TO TREAT THAT
NATION DIFFERENTLY.
YOU MAY NOT WANT TO, IT MAY BE
UNFAIR, BUT THAT'S WHY NATIONS
SEEK NUCLEAR WEAPONS, BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T BOSS THEM AROUND.
IF YOU IGNORE THE POSSIBILITY
THAT YOUR ENTIRE POPULATION
COULD BE KILLED, YOU'RE NOT FIT
FOR LEADERSHIP, BECAUSE YOU'RE
INSANE.
OUR LEADERS ARE THERE, INSANE.
>> THERE'S A SENSE PURPOSELY
CULTIVATED TO BELIEVE THAT THE
USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS REALLY
ISN'T A REALISTIC POSSIBILITY,
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE HAD THE USE
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN OUR --
IN -- IN THE LAST CENTURY, WHEN
THE U.S. DID IT -- IN JAPAN FOR
WORLD WAR II.
WE CAME VERY CLOSE ON AT LEAST
TWO OR THREE OCCASIONS, THE U.S.
AND RUSSIA DID, THESE TWO SAME
COUNTRIES, TO EXCHANGING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AND RISKING NUCLEAR
ANNIHILATION, INCLUDING THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRIES, BECAUSE THE
U.S. FELT THAT THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT IN CUBA WAS SO
THREATENING WE'D HAVE A NUCLEAR
WAR OVER IT.
IT IS MADNESS TO ASSUME THAT FOR
RUSSIA, WHAT IS AN EXISTENTIAL
WAR, IF THEY ACTUALLY START
LOSING IT, OR NATO REALLY STARTS
ESCALATING, WAS WE'VE BEEN
DOING, THAT THE CHANCES OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN USING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IS ZERO.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS DELUSION
THAT I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
OPERATING UNDER.
>> Tucker: THAT'S TOTALLY --
IT'S THE CRAZIEST THING I'VE
EVER SEEN.
LET ME ASK YOU, SINCE YOU WERE
IN BRAZIL, WE SPOKE YOU FOR OUR
DOCUMENTARY THERE, AND WE WERE
IN RIO, AND UP UNTIL ABOUT 20
MINUTES AGO, WE WERE TOLD THAT
BOLSON ARO WOULD GET FLATTENED.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE?
>> THEY GOT RACES WRONG BY 20 OR
30 POINTS, ALWAYS IN FAVOR OF
THE BRAZILIAN LEFT.
THERE'S A RUNOFF BETWEEN THE
LEFT WING CANDIDATE.
I WOULD PUT BOLSONARO IS THE
FAVORITE.
EVEN IF LOSES, THE MOVEMENT THAT
HE CREATED, IS INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL.
THE BIGGEST PARTY IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE.
THEY HAVE GOVERNORSHIPS OF THE
KEY STATES.
NONE OF THE POLLING DATA, OR THE
BRAZILIAN MEDIA, PREDICTED THAT,
BECAUSE THEY WANTED, I THINK, TO
MANIPULATE THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION THROUGH THESE
FRAUDULENT POLLING -- OR AT THE
VERY LEAST POLLING THAT'S
RADICALLY WRONG.
WE'LL SEE OCTOBER 30th WHEN
THE RUNOFF TAKES PLACE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, NOT ONLY IN
BRAZIL.
I WANT TO HIT YOU WITH BREAKING
NEWS HERE.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
AIR RAID SIRENS BLARING ACROSS
TOKYO, OBVIOUSLY THE BIGGEST
CITY IN THE WORLD, IN JAPAN,
GOVERNMENT THERE WARNING THAT
NORTH KOREA HAS APPARENTLY FILEC
MISSILE INTO JAPANESE AIRSPACE.
THE JAPANESE IN TOKYO BEING
INSTRUCTED TO SHELTER INDOORS
IMMEDIATELY.
OF COURSE WE BELIEVE OUR VICE
PRESIDENT WAS JUST IN SOUTH
KOREA.
GLENN, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I MEAN, IT'S HARD TO ANALYZE
THE SPECIFIC EVENT, SINCE IT
JUST HAPPENED.
BUT WHAT I WILL USE IT FOR IS,
AGAIN, TO SAY WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE MAJOR
COUNTRIES USING LONG-RANGE
MISSILES, A LOT OF TIMES THE
REASON ESCALATION HAPPENS ISN'T
EVEN BECAUSE THE COUNTRIES WANT
IT TO, BUT WHEN HOSTILITIES ARE
INTENSIFIED ENOUGH,
MISCOMMUNICATION AND
MISPERCEPTION HAPPEN.
THAT'S WHEN YOU GET INVOLVED IN
A WAR LIKE THE ONE IN UKRAINE
THINGS ARE INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS.
THE WORLD IS A DANGEROUS PLACE.
THESE WEAPONS CAN KILL HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AT ONCE.
WE'RE PLAYING WITH FIRE, TUCKER,
BY NOT EVEN BEING WILLING TO
DEBATE THIS OUT OF FEAR THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE CALLED NAMES.
I THINK IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF IT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
I MEAN, IT'S OUR JOB TO SAY WHAT
WE THINK IS TRUE, REGARDLESS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT PICTURES RIGHT
NOW OF AIR RAID SIRENS IN TOKYO.
CERTAINLY ALL OF THIS ADDS UP,
AT LEAST AT FIRST GLANCE, TO A
WORLD IN TURMOIL, THAT IS IN
SOME VERY DEEP WAY RESETTING.
YOU KNOW, THOSE POSTWAR NORMS
AND INSTITUTIONS THAT WE OFTEN
HEAR THE FOREIGN POLICY PEOPLE
DESCRIBE SEEM TO BE COLLAPSING
TO SOME EXTENT.
>> IT IS TRUE THAT NONE OF THESE
THINGS HAPPEN, DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THE RUSSIANS ANNEXED CRIMEA
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THEY INVADED GEORGIA UNDER
PRESIDENT BUSH.
NOTHING HAPPENED DURING THE
TRUMP YEARS WITH ALL OF THIS
KIND OF INSTABILITY.
WE'RE SEEING IT AGAIN.
THE REASON IN PART IS BECAUSE
PEOPLE LOOK AT JOE BIDEN AND
KNOW HE'S A DOTTERRING LEADER
WHO'S LOST MUCH, IF NOT MOST OF
HIS MENTAL CAPACITY.
A LOT OF COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD SEE THAT AS A SIGNAL TO
START EXPLOITING THE SITUATION
FOR THEIR OWN INTEREST.
I BELIEVE THAT'S EXACTLY A
FACTOR.
>> Tucker: IT'S THE DRUNK
STEPDAD, DO WHAT YOU WAN